ces habitants de bart moutons bien du
mal à en croire leurs yeux
leur immeuble vient d'être bombardés par
l'armée russe des morceaux de l'édifice
sont d'ailleurs visibles au sol un peu
partout
un bâtiment de plusieurs étages a été
détruit ainsi que plusieurs maisons les
policiers vont enquêter sur ce crime
avec les sauveteurs ils ont sorti
plusieurs personnes des décombres d'une
maison qui a été touché de plein fouet
un choc car certains vivent ici depuis
des décennies on compte plusieurs
blessés tous ont été pris en charge par
des services d'urgence toujours
opérationnel et ce malgré l'âpreté de la
guerre
frappe russe aussi sur une autre ville
de la région de donetsk à sauvian sq
visés par des bombardements massifs
selon le maire ce grand marché a pris
feu obligeant les pompiers à intervenir
pour les ukrainiens l'heure n'est pas à
l'optimisme
i
après la prise de la province de
louhansk ce week end le kremlin a
désormais jeté son dévolu sur celle
voisine de donetsk
fief le dit d'ailleurs publiquement il
va lui falloir tenir sa ligne de défense
entre bar goûter ce l'audience qu si
elle ne veut pas que les russes
contrôlent un jour tout le dombass
mais avec une artillerie capable de
tirer des dizaines de milliers d'obus
chaque jour l'envahissent russe a une
force de frappe bien supérieure à celle
de son adversaire ukrainien